a digital technology professor at the
Ontario Institute of Technology has
written an interesting piece on the elf
on the shelf do you know about the elf
on the shelf if not let's take a look
[Music]
okay so the Alpha on the shelf basically
sits on the shelf then is watching the
kids so that he can report back to Santa
where the kids have been naughty or nice
well Laura Pinto who is this professor
she wrote a piece on this basically
saying that these that were training
kids to be accustomed to a surveillance
state so let's take a look at a little
bit of what she wrote she wrote you're
teaching kids a bigger lesson which is
that it's okay for other people to spy
on you and you're not entitled to
privacy the elf is an external form of
non-familial surveillance if you grow up
thinking that it's cool for the elves to
watch me and report back to Santa well
then it's cool for the NSA to watch me
and report back to the government I
can't believe I'm gonna say this but I
sort of agree with her sentiment we
talked so much about the NSA and the CIA
and spying and hacking and blah blah
blah
are we conditioning these kids I have a
feeling Andy doesn't quite agree
so Andy you're you're not with me no I
I'm with you I just think the real thing
that conditions kids to living in a
surveillance state is living in a
surveillance that like this [ __ ] elf
that's like sitting on the shelf I mean
there's a lot of bigger issues like I
don't know going to school and like
being you know like I was in a place
with like 300 cameras all over you know
all the time watching you to make sure
that the school North Central High
School in Indianapolis Indiana well a
kids are horrible I can attest to it you
know thank God we had surveillance
because like you know saying you were on
the bullying end of things I think I
will say that the main villain was
family cat may or may not have been shot
with what may or may not have been a BB
gun by someone who I may or may not have
known who may or may not have lived next
to what probably would have been my high
school and pretty sure whatever you're
saying that cat that's probably still
within the statute of limitations if you
killed the cat I didn't though it wasn't
me oh but it's someone who was then
comment later by those by the cameras
the thing is it's like I
somewhere in that long-winded attempt at
humor yeah you were on the witness stand
right exactly you know I think that we
are conditioned because of the fact that
we are just surrounded by cameras and
and surveillance all the time okay so
the so the bigger point is that these
cameras are everywhere actually when I
was driving here today I drove by a
Google car with the big camera out there
I mean right down on La Cienega they're
filming everybody or they're taking
pictures format or whatever it is yeah
but the idea that this is in the house
this concept I get it's just an it's
just an idea and I know this is just a
paper and it's sort of a law it's a
philosophical debate they're not
actually putting cameras to watch and
record these kids now but whatnot but it
seems to me the the the greater problem
with this is that this is how you're
motivating kids to be good people
because someone is watching it right and
it's and then you get a reward because
this thing that's watching you reports
to this fake guy you know I mean I'm so
sorry but you know I yeah I find that
more disturbing than anything and then
and then basically that is what is what
drives society be good people because
we're watching you right so I think
absolutely because because it's good to
be a good person right but be it because
we're watching you not because it's
inherently or intrinsically good so
actually it sort of seems to be that
we're all kind of in agreement here
because there's the cat there's the
there's the real surveillance stuff
right that's going on and the idea but
those two things go hand in yeah but I
don't know that like I mean I think it's
such a tough it's a tough line to cross
there I mean I think this is just sort
of a creepier thing so it's easier for
us to point it and say like this is
freaky yeah but I think they'll like
they're a little freaky yeah just like
that little guy
yeah yeah I mean I would say like I
don't know I think that we do need a
little bit of authority
watching them change into their pajamas
what is that creepy
it's like voyeuristic in a lot of ways I
bet you I mean joking aside like I bet
there are kids that literally turn the
off around when they're changing or
something his his arms will be clasped
behind his back
all right so final thought on this you
think also between the the real stuff so
the real cameras that are everywhere in
the NSA and that stuff which we all
agree on and then the idea of this stuff
do you think kids that are growing up
now with all this do you think they'll
ever revolt against it like I think I'm
part of that last generation that had it
the other way you know what I mean if
you're somewhere in your 30s maybe upper
20s you didn't fully grow up with all
this but they really are growing up with
all this do you think they will ever I
think so I think revolt all we
ultimately always happens that's what
happens you built you build up to a
boiling point there's a revolution and
there's change and then you start
building up again to another boiling
point that seems to be the way history
goes it's like will we be to just much
enthralled in our Facebook scroll do you
think we're just gonna you think we're
on our way to another paradigm of
humanity I think we might be I sort of I
think that ebb and flow thing and that
there are cyclical things yeah but then
on the other hand I do think that the
technology is becoming so powerful that
it's actually changing the way we are
like we're all no we're just gonna be
little microbes we're little microbes in
a big matrix II thing what do you think
comment right down below
[Music]